and then looking at alpha information on thinking about optimizing textures so we
want to look at the difference between some kind of foliage and on the alpha
channel we've got the masking for that foliage so that you can you know not
see that green background and it renders properly as a bush for example
versus adding another texture so an alpha texture to the opacity mask and
what the trade-off is between adding an extra texture sample versus just packing
it into your alpha channel so if we look at the embedded alpha versus the
separate alpha we're getting a higher visual fidelity from the separate alpha
it is including an extra texture but again it's the trade-off between do
you want your alpha maps on a separate texture sample and you can pack these
all into one RGB texture sample or do you want to embed the alpha inside of that
one texture so if we go back to the previous slide you have the RGB going
straight into the base color and then the the alpha channel is packed into
that alpha so that we can plug it into the opacity mask whereas on the
second separate alpha example we are just using the R channel to have our
opacity mask so again it's an extra texture map but you can compress them
in such a way whereas if we go to the next slide that we can compress without
alpha if we tick that box then we're making some affordances for our texture
so that in our channels in Photoshop or whatever package you might be using we
can just see the RGB channels that we've not got an alpha channel so
therefore we can make some affordances to say okay compress this without an
alpha channel we can have our compression settings as masks no sRGB
and then just make sure the sRGB isn't checked and therefore when we go to see
the incorrect versus correct with the sRGB disabling you can
see that there's a crispness to the correct side which is the right hand
side if we're looking at maybe some of the small branch detail or just anywhere
where there's those extra little details with the branches coming out you
can see that when it's incorrect unreal is trying to optimize things but
it's not doing a great job at trying to figure out the rendering here
because it's missing some crucial information that just makes that asset
look correct so it's good to consider how you're packing your alpha channels and
which approach you're taking whether you're packing them into the one texture
sample or using a different alpha to then set that opacity